c'est dans une région de vignobles
vignoble que se sont tenues les journées
du livre et du vin à saumur plusieurs
dizaines d'auteurs en quête de bons
petits crus et de bons mots pour les
qualifiés jean yves perrin vincent
vallières des livres du vin des
bataillons d'auteurs connus ou moins
connus
le concept semble séduisant il ne suffit
pourtant pas à faire venir un large
public
alors à saumur les préposés aux
signatures patiente comme ils peuvent
question préférence du libre est due à
un gène pense qu'on va et il le prouve
chez les frères foucault viticulteurs
dans l'appellation saumur champigny en
compagnie de régine deforges et claude
chabrol de grands amateurs de vin une
dégustation de derrière les taux de 16
ans barry mots du vin affaire de
spécialiste mode amateurs aussi quand il
lui faut décrire un 20-6 les par les
sensations éprouvées
nous devrons sûrement de précision
donnée essentielle et c'est juste la
paille a pas d'erreur
vous êtes 15 1 s'ouvre vous dit tout
comprenez on comprend énormément de
choses il ya toute une poésie non
manière un peu comparable de juger un
vin à livre c'est vrai que c'est pas
tout à fait faux il y a des livres ils
sont de grands livres et qui ne se donne
pas une enquête mais il faut que pages
et quelques points quelques dizaines de
pages avoue que le que le livre pollen
peine son ampleur prennent tout c'est
toute sa plénitude
alors c'est quoi ça alors ça c'est
joyeux et s'il fallait un mot un seul
pour qualifier ce vin ce serait ma roue
la chorale connaisseurs